Look at the stars,
top 10% performers versus people who are
just mediocre.
Just at the average.
Uh,
there's a way to do a systematic
analysis of the capabilities or
competencies that stars have that you
don't find that the average David
Mcclellan,
it was one of the developers of this.
Really,
my work in emotional intelligence looks
at that because it turns out,
particularly for leadership,
most of the competencies that
distinguish outstanding leaders have
nothing to do with Iq,
with academic intelligence.
They're in this other domain,
uh,
whether people are getting more
competitive or not a more viciously
competitive,
I think people have always been
viciously competitive.
However,
people who are the most effective,
uh,
tend to be competitive in a different
way.
They compete with themselves.
They have,
as I said,
they have very high standards for
performance and they're continually
trying to understand how to learn to do
better.
And that's the more effective way to
compete,
improve your own performance,
not run against the other guy
necessarily.
Here's the problem with Malcolm's book.
You know,
he talks about cohorts that have been
privileged by accident,
by experience,
but one of them,
for example,
is a,
as I remember,
Jewish lawyers who were born in the
1930s and some of them were
spectacularly successful.
The problem is he didn't take a sample
of all Jewish lawyers born in thirties
there are also certain to be failures
among them,
and his model doesn't really explain
what distinguishes the failures from the
outliers,
which,
so it's a good beginning,
but you know,
I was waiting for the other shoe to drop
and then the book ended.
But Malcolm is a wonderful writer.
I really don't know.